some people associate instant noodles
with broke college students but instant
ramen wasn't created for a bunch of
hungry 20 year olds the man who invented
them was much more ambitious he set out
to solve a hunger crisis in Japan after
World War two food shortages plagued
Japanese cities so the u.s. supplied
wheat flour and encouraged the Japanese
to make bread one man named Momofuku
Ando didn't understand why his people
would make bread instead of noodles
something that was already part of their
culture undo decided to take matters
into his own hands and create a new
ramen made to last he spent a year
trying to figure out how to preserve the
noodles he needed a non perishable tasty
and easy recipe but it was a challenge
to maintain the robust flavors and
unique texture that most people were
accustomed to it wasn't until his wife
was making dinner one night and he threw
some noodles in a bowl of hot tempura
oil that he realized flash frying the
noodles was the answer he had been
looking for this method not only
dehydrated them
it left small perforations that allowed
the noodles to recut quickly and there
you have it instant ramen noodles became
an instant success undos products gained
notoriety when he introduced the
packaged ramen in the 1950s and later
cup noodles in 1978 his company began
selling upwards of 40 billion units
every year and Momofuku ndu became a
culinary icon in Japan
so the next time you heat up a cup of
instant noodles remember you're slurping
down a little piece of history